so if you could only watch one game
tonight Jets Giants Redskins Browns
Chargers Cardinals with the rookie
quarterbacks on display we'll start
there with Peter King who joins us Pete
good morning if you could only watch one
of these games tonight which one are you
more interested in
I guess I'd want to watch Kyler Murray's
first NFL throws and what kind of
offense Kliff Kingsbury has I mean
that's going to be the most interesting
thing in this entire training camp
season so he plays tonight I would be
watching that one can he be a running
quarterback should he be a running back
no no they're not going to have him do
that all the time you can't do it in the
NFL he won't last
when I was at Ravens camp Lamar Jackson
was I think the transformation of Lamar
Jackson was underway he would sprint to
the line and he would stop a couple feet
short of the line and most snaps I saw
he was throwing the ball he wouldn't
continue running that's what you want a
quarterback to do in the NFL if your
throw if you're running whatever Lamar
did last year 15 times a game I've heard
I don't know the number but it's just
it's not a recipe for long-term success
you stay in the pocket you can be like
Brees and Brady and clay T or 40 this
situation with Washington with Dwayne
Haskins is this an is this quarterback
competition truly open I don't have any
idea I wasn't there but I would assume
they don't think J Haskins gonna start
but I don't I've been to 14 places
that's not one of them you visited
Broncos Jets Ravens Eagles Panthers
Falcons Buccaneers Dolphins Saints Jags
Colts Packers Browns Steelers the the
busy they're the best the the best
morale was at what camp what a good
question that is I would say there
wasn't better morale than at the Denver
Broncos they love Vic Fangio they love
this message they love fundamentals
fundamentals fundamentals Von Miller
loves them I don't know if they're going
to be that good but they're really like
Sanji oh right now yeah I'm always
curious when we watch a game that that
we all of a sudden have this in pray
it'll be a preseason game and all of a
sudden we can read into it like what
kind of team they're going to be no way
I mean I go to practice everybody say
what you think the other day I was at
Browns campaign
what's gonna give the Browns how do I
know I made a great leaping catch in the
endzone
what's surprising about that I mean
that's so I can't really tell none of us
can tell training camp there's a lot of
mirages there in my opinion the Antonio
Browns story we for a guy who loves to
talk and post things we haven't heard
much from him a coach who likes to talk
haven't heard much and an agent who
represents Antonio Brown and Drew
Rosenhaus loves to talk and we haven't
heard much about this how serious is
this situation do you think for Brown
and the Raiders Dan I only know what
I've read and it just seems weird that
the apparent frostbitten foot is going
to heal overnight but I mean I have not
done a lot of research and/or reporting
on frostbite so I don't know but it's a
little bit weird that when you go into
one of those cryo chambers that
apparently you don't follow the
directions or instructions of your you
know of your you know of your trainer
whoever put you in the cryo chamber
that's a weird weird story yeah I've
done the cryotherapy a couple of times
yeah I have socks on yeah well they tell
you dry off you have these big thick
socks and you have you know shoes that
you wear in and you wear gloves I don't
know how somebody could have allowed him
to get in there without shoes or socks
on yeah that'll be a good hard knock
sensor if they talk about it yes yeah
yeah the cowboy situation who blinks
first in all of this Cele it'll play
opening day how can Jerry Jones allow
him not to I mean he's the biggest piece
of their offense without any question
what
I can't imagine that Jerry Jones allows
this season to start without his
franchise 24 year old running back yeah
I'm there with you you know Jerry
desperately wants to win a Super Bowl
and I can't imagine he would jeopardize
that because this seems like maybe the
best cowboy team we've seen in a while
would you uh I think it is okay see and
guess what what this is hilarious I got
stuck for talking on a cell phone
because I'm talking to you so now I have
to hang up the cops come to the car
sorry about that
do you want me to talk to the police
officer I thought he had a hot ticket a
cowboy I thought he was getting breaking
news yeah he just got text about feet or
something frostbite like Ezekiel Elliott
was gonna be in camp
okay who wants a piece of the bet does
Peter King get a warning or get a ticket
new poll question and does he drop what
he does for a living in some fashion cuz
it is pretty famous guy if you like I
felt that's why I wanted to say let me
talk to the police officer that I called
you and you accidentally picked up the
phone I was gonna try to help him out
there
spike Peter one of the speaker phones or
something bluetooth yeah why didn't
Peter have that what part of the cut is
he he lives in New York City now I
believe no we moved to Brooklyn to
Brooklyn yeah
so I wonder where he was driving I've
been pulled over in Brooklyn for talking
on a cell phone they're not very kind no
I got pulled over years ago in New York
on a and I was lost and I was actually
calling my wife you know to get
directions and the guy just pointed at
me and then pointed to the side of the
road and I pulled over and he was not in
the mood for anything
maybe it's like license registrations I
said yeah you know I was just called he
said save it it's David I go look okay
but I was just on the phone I'm lost in
here yeah let's say that went back came
back ticket that's it
ballgame yes Paul so the Peter King bet
I didn't know he lived in New York now
Peter probably has a red
socks hat on or red socks shirt which
isn't gonna help him with the Popo
mmm-hmm
I'm gonna say Pete gets popped here I
say he gets off oh you do
yeah I'm gonna go ticket yes yes yeah I
see him getting written up yeah yeah I
agree New York doesn't care really who
you are now if he calls back do we do a
buy or sell buy her cell Oh
cell service yellow or like jail cell oh
okay the aforementioned Peter King
joining us again he had a little run-in
with the law he was on his phone and
Peter we have a bet whether you got a
ticket or not and let me see
I say you got a ticket seaton says he
got a ticket
McLovin said he got a ticket Paul II
said no Fritzi said no Peter King the
answer is did you get a ticket of course
I got it I mean I said to the cop I'm on
with Dan Patrick I said here's your
ticket yeah that was that was fun
well why didn't you lie and say you're
on hey as I said the Fricke it's a good
thing I'm fabulously well you should
have said you're on with Mike and Mike
or something like that or Mike and Mike
don't exist anymore that's you're so
square I am Mike and tray or Golic and
Wingo yeah goalie can Wingo that's not
that's Peter I'm sorry I'm but you know
why this is good this will give us a
chance to go to talk about the camps I
actually didn't see where I was I know I
started to think well I ask all these
questions at camps where he didn't even
go and I had all of those camp sites
right in front of me they're nice okay
you went to see the Packers right yeah
okay I don't know what was said about
that practice scrimmage that they had
with the Texans and
Leflore the head coach he says hey I
loved it and then Rodgers says hey be
nice if maybe we waited to do 12 or 13
more years before we did this again I
know I shouldn't read into something as
you know silly as this but is this like
is this potentially a big issue well I
don't think it's a big issue but
understand this Dan you know Aaron
Rodgers had never in his career
practiced against another team so how
would he know what to expect you got a
bunch of guys on the Texans some of whom
are trying to make the team or trying to
work play for playing time Bill O'Brien
had made a big deal about this you're
going up against his great offense and
as I was watching this what was I
thought was really interesting look and
it's JJ Watt because you feel like you
figure he's always gonna play even in
training camp he's gonna play really
hard he was chasing Rodgers so hard that
and this I didn't even know this until
after he left that they said he'd
slightly tweaked his groin and and so
they were they were practicing very very
hard but again look I went to the
Steelers yesterday then those guys are
beating the tar out of each other
so I mean maybe the Packers had just
gotten used to over the years of not
having much contact at all in training
camp I don't know that but what they
said surprising it didn't seem
particularly violent to me I'm also
curious with the Steelers did it sound
different when you were there without
yeah no question okay and I asked Tom
one about it yesterday
about you know it's sort of a placid
camp you know a year ago it's the lay
beyond all doubt and there's always
little skirmishes and brush fires with
Antonia Brown if that Tomlin is not
taking the bait but I can tell you you
know I've I've been around this team
quite a bit over the years this is a
much happier team the offensive line is
it is exceedingly happy you know
compared to always sort of feeling that
you know their their character was under
fire and Roethlisberger's character was
under fire
bye-bye Antonio Brown it's just just
kind of a weird
vibe but I spent I don't know maybe 2025
minutes with juju Smith Shuster and I
can tell you they're going to say all
the right things but you just get the
feeling like and and and then this is a
crazy thing I was I was telling one of
my buddies who plays fantasy football I
said if I were you in the last round
take Ryan Switzer they say who's Ryan
Switzer well he's this short receiver
from North Carolina drafted by the
Cowboys went to Oakland last year was
traded to the Steelers Roethlisberger
and he have had an off season together I
think he's going to take up a lot of a
lot of the slack of Antonio Brown he was
all over that first team offense
yesterday he's a felon Peter King
joining us on loan from words I'm also
curious to watch the Giants with Daniel
Jones I don't know how much he plays I
guess he's gonna play a little bit more
than you would think he's the backup
quarterback but that job's not open
right the Eli is gonna be the same okay
to open and Dan I would I think he's
gonna play a lot in the preseason
because I don't think Eli is gonna play
much at all I mean quarterbacks all
around the league you know Golf
Garoppolo
and there's a lot of quarterbacks it
won't play at all in the preseason but
the reason why he'll play a lot is
because I think the Giants figure that
he's probably not going to play much
during the season them I have not been
to their camp and I have not asked Pat
Sherman a question so this is simply me
looking at it from 10,000 feet I don't
know but what I figure is as long as
they are competitive and Eli Manning is
playing Eli Manning competitive football
they're not going to make a quarterback
change now if they're 1 in 6 in
mid-october and Eli's leading the league
in interceptions well here comes Daniel
Jones it's coming we it's just not going
to come until the Giants Giants are
ready to do it what do you make of all
the hype with the Cleveland Browns I
think it's real and it's spectacular
[Laughter]
okay you know Dan I think I think what
was what was interesting the other day
okay
so let me give you the scene at
brown-skinned I'm standing in the end
zone and coming right at me is Odell
Beckham and he makes a circus catch
keeps both feet inbounds and he comes
down with the ball and the crowded
training camp goes nuts everybody's
excited and everybody's oh my god we're
back we're gonna be great and everything
and look I think that there could come a
point on December 1st if they're all
healthy and the two receivers you know
playing in tandem or Jarvis Landry Odell
Beckham jr. David and Joe go at tight
end and then if they're two backs
rotating sometimes playing at the same
time you know or Kareem Hunt and Nick
Chubb that is as good a skill position
combination as any team has in football
so everything looks good all looks great
I'll tell you the two things that I
would wonder about number one Odell
Beckham's health he's not been and I've
been able to stay healthy the last two
years and he plays at a breakneck speed
and he's a little guy so we'll see he
was fine his first three years last two
not so much and then the other thing
that I worry about is their offensive
line I just think it's it's it's right
as of right now it's run-of-the-mill and
that's gonna be a challenge because
Baker Mayfield in my opinion you can't
be hitting them all the time so those
are the two things but again it was
funny I talked to my comment about this
yesterday and and you would think oh my
god was great when we had two automatic
wins against Cleveland he loves it for
football and I think that is the that's
the feeling that so many people have
right now isn't it great that the Browns
are finally going to be fun they haven't
fun in forever
I guess one of my questions is still
Freddie kitchens in that role and you
know does it overwhelm him there you got
a lot of personalities the expectation
level is really high there and it felt
like his ascension was pretty quick from
where he was to becoming the head coach
you know Dan here's the funny thing
about Freddie kitchens okay a year ago
at this time he was
probably lowest man on the assistant
coach totem pole kind of got hired by
Todd Haley who really knew him from
Arizona and and just to be the running
backs coach and when he got the job as
the play caller midway through the
season the guys like Jarvis Landry and
Baker Mayfield fell in love with him
because you would think that a former
highly conservative quarterback at
Alabama which Freddie kitchens was 25
years ago you would think that he would
be Gene Stallings or whatever you know a
real old fashioned old-time guy but you
know Dan there was a game last year
where he played three running backs in
tandem three plays in a row there were
games last year where he is 13 personnel
three tight ends on the field more than
ten times nobody there most place teams
don't have any tight ends and I'm
exaggerating but you know what I mean
yeah he is a he is a very imaginative
guy in and the second thing is a lot of
first-year head coaches who are
anonymous don't do the other what I
would call the fifth quarter very well
in dealing with all of the bullcrap that
a head coach has to deal with for
instance I counted the other day he
spent over two hours the Browns are
famous now and everybody is in Adam
Kilgore from the Washington Post was
there there's a bunch of out-of-town
people out of town media there and and
and and all of these guys are there and
he spent 20 minute I spent close to a
half hour with him and so he is okay
with doing that and and and that right
now is what the coach of the Cleveland
Browns kind of has to do yeah the
expectation levels are just through the
roof you know talking about them as a
Super Bowl contender and it's almost
like if they win 10 games and don't make
a wild card people in Cleveland will
will have a funeral it's it'll be
crushing for them yeah I think the
expectation level way too high for that
team there's still some question marks
and and I do think you know the the
offense has been you know most talked
about for the you know obvious reasons I
think
defense is going to be an elite defense
and might be a bigger reason why this
team is a playoff team or you know
potentially even bigger than that I
think adding Olivier Vernon look as much
as I don't like subtracting Zeidler
sending them to the Giants for Olivier
Vernon essentially I don't like that to
the offense I really like Olivier Vernon
who who I think gives them the kind of
bookend along with Miles Garrett that
they've really been looking for yep
no a lot of fun and preseason coming up
tonight Peter thank you
you know once again if I can split the
bill I'd be more than happy to no Dan
I'll tell you this you know what you can
do you can buy me a fantastic cab the
next time I'm in Milford and we'll call
it even nice glass of cab the next time
I see you I'll make sure that I get you
a nice bottle of cab you and I you and I
will you and I you and I'll have a drink
together thank you Peter
all right hey you take care Dan that's
Peter King now felon got arrested for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]